mais moi j'appuie hier à ce que je veux
des jobs pour les gaz par milliard et
les gaspésienne je veux qu'ils vivent
dans la dignité non un emploi bien
rémunéré aux ligues excusé me gêne pas
de gaspillage ou pose une question là
vous demain matin et liez vous avant
emprunter 1 million pour vous créer un
emploi comme quoi il y avait 10 et créer
des emplois il sait qu'il y en ait moins
de chômage est exactement comparable à
celui de l'ontario voyons aussi tir de
l'état que l'inflation à été plus loin
de shanghai allemande étant évidemment
la croissance des revenus en on assez
unique en soi c'est là ya pas d'argent
sans rien faire - personnes à l'aide
sociale qui n'a jamais eu de tous les
temps